So if we repeatedly sounded the tone over and over and did not follow it with
meat powder, we would see the process of extinction. Eventually the dog would
start to salivate less, and then he would stop salivating all together. Here we
could say the classically conditioned response has been extinguished. However,
if we wait 2 weeks, and we come into the lab and we present the conditioned
stimulus, or we sound the tone, we see then the dog, in fact, will salivate.
That salivation is termed spontaneous recovery. Spontaneous recovery happens
when a previously conditioned response has been extinguished, and it occurs
again when the conditioned stimulus is presented at a later time. So let's take
a look at how these last 3 terms in classical conditioning. Aquisition,
extinction, and spontaneous recovery occur.